our economic recovery and our ability to
build back better
stronger and more secure and while
the crisis had these crises have caused
real damage i explained how it will cost
more hundreds of billions of dollars
more
to undo the harm i talked about our
moral obligation to act
and about the clear economic consensus
that making the investments i'm calling
for that the resource that the required
deficit spending as the original plans
have as well
are necessary to get us out of this deep
hole we find ourselves in as a nation
i also talked about our seriousness of
purpose
our clear plan with transparency and
accountability and why our
call for unity is equally necessary
unity is not some pie in the sky dream
it's a practical step
to getting things done we didn't get
into all of this overnight
we won't get out of it overnight either
but we will get through it and we'll get
through it together
and today i'd like to talk more about
what that means and
sparing no effort i mean sparing no
effort to get americans vaccinated
vice president harrison and i we just
received a briefing from our covetee
truthfully we remain in a very dark
winter
infection rates are up 34 percent
more people are being hospitalized
because of covet than ever before
we're up to between three and four
thousand deaths per day
as we approach a grim milestone of 400
000 deaths in america that's staggering
to state the obvious
i know the pain that so many of your
experience
experiencing right now starting
by sitting down for breakfast this
morning and stared at an empty chair
on the kitchen table where a loved one
used to sit
laugh talk about how you love one
another
i know the frustration that we're all
feeling
almost a year later we're still far from
back to normal
the honest truth is this things will get
worse before they get better i told you
i always level with you
you know and the policy changes that
we're going to be making
are going to take time to show up in the
coveted statistics
not just statistics it's people's lives
people getting infected today don't show
up in case counts for weeks
those who perish from this disease die
weeks after exposure so it will take
time
but i know there are things we can do
and we can do them now
for example the vaccines offer
so much hope we're grateful for the
scientists and researchers and
everyone who participated in the
clinical trials
we're grateful for the integrity of the
process the rigorous view and testing
that's led to millions of people around
the world already being vaccinated
safely
but the vaccine rollout in the united
states has been a dismal failure thus
far
in today's briefing we discussed five
things
five things we'll do attempt to turn
things around
five things to turn frustration into
motivation
five things to help us meet our goal of
100 million
shots by the end of our first 100 days
in office
some wonder if we're reaching too far
for that goal
is it achievable it's a legitimate
question to ask
let me be clear i'm convinced we can get
it done
and this is a time to set big goals to
pursue them with
courage and conviction because the
health of the nation is literally at
stake
first we will immediately work with
states
to open up vaccinations to more priority
groups
the process of establishing priority
groups is driven by
science but the problem is
implementation
has been too rigid and confusing
if you were to ask most people today
they couldn't tell you who exactly is
getting vaccinated
what they do know is there are tens of
millions of doses of vaccine
sitting unused in freezers around the
country
while people who want and need the
vaccine can't get it
we'll fix the problem by encouraging
states to allow more people to get
vaccinated beyond
health care workers and move through
those groups as quickly
as they think we can
that includes anyone 65 years or older
a population that has accounted for over
80 percent
of the deaths to date 80 percent that's
to date
we also have to continue vaccinating
front line essential workers like
educators first responders
grocery car work store workers etc
it won't mean that everyone in this
group will get vaccinated immediately
as the supply is not where it needs to
be
but it will mean that vaccines become
available as they can become available
will reach more people who need them
will reach out and get
the vaccine used the second thing we're
going to change
if we're getting more people vaccinated
then we need more
vaccination sites that's where we're
going to harness the full resources of
the federal government to establish
thousands of community vaccination
centers
on my first day in office i'll instruct
the federal emergency management agency
fema
to begin setting up the first of these
centers
by the end of our first month in office
we'll have 100
federally supported centers across the
nation that will
ultimately vaccinate millions of people
think of places that are convenient and
accessible
school gymnasiums sports stadiums
community centers
we've already had productive
conversations with bipartisan groups of
county officials
mayors governors tribal leaders leaders
of the private sector
who shared their ideas with us about
this effort
and as we build them we're going to make
sure
it's done equitably we're going to make
sure there are vaccination centers and
communities
hit hardest by the pandemic in black and
latino communities in rural communities
as well
within the first month of our
administration we're going to deploy
mobile clinics mobile clinics moving
from community community
that will partner with community health
centers and local primary care doctors
to offer vaccines to hard hit
and hard to reach communities in cities
small towns and in rural communities and
to staff up these centers
we will mobilize thousands of clinical
and non-clinical professionals
think of the people deployed that we
deploy in natural disasters
experts from the federal emergency
management
from fema and the center of disease
control
our public health service commission
corps
our military medical personnel our first
responders
additionally we're going to expand the
pool of medical professionals
including retired healthcare workers who
can administer the vaccine
and to ensure we have enough vaccinators
to meet the nation's needs
as we ramp this up and as governors of
both parties have asked
our administration will reimburse states
100
when their national guard is deployed in
the fight against coven
we'll provide resources to help states
cover the cost of personnel
vaccinators administrative staff
as well of supplies like dry ice and
laptops and protective equipment
the third change we're going to make is
we're going to fully
activate the pharmaceutic the pharmacies
across the country
to get the vaccination into more arms as
quickly as possible
millions of americans now turn to the
local pharmacies
every day for their medicines flu shots
and much more
we're going to immediately start new
major efforts
working directly with both independent
and chained pharmacies
to get americans vaccinated this program
will extend
expand beyond access in neighborhoods
across
country across the country so that we
can make
you can make an appointment and get your
shot conveniently show up on a
particular time
and get it done quickly the fourth thing
we're going to do is we're going to use
the full strength of the federal
government to ramp up supply
of the vaccines as i said before
we'll use the defense production act to
work with private industry
to accelerate the making of materials
needed to supply and
administer the vaccine from the tubes
and syringes and syringes
to protective equipment and i've already
asked the team
and we have identified the suppliers
who are prepared to work with their with
our teams and we're going to work with
their teams
not someday we're going to do this when
i say we're going to
invoke the defense production act said
go out even though we don't have the
authority now go out and identify
those companies that are prepared and
will be able to do what we're going to
ask
as we made clear earlier this month the
trump administration's policy of holding
back
close to half the supply of the vaccines
available
did not make sense our administration
will release the vast majority of the
vaccines
when they are available so more people
can get vaccinated quickly
while still retaining a small reserve
for any unseen
shortage or delays but let me be clear
we are not changing the fda's
recommendation
and its recommended dosing schedules we
believe it's critical that everyone
should get
two doses within the fda recommended
time frame so we're not doing away with
that
that availability fifth
we will always be honest and transparent
about where we stand
both the good news as well as the bad
we're going to make sure state and local
officials know how much supply they'll
be getting
and when they can expect to get it so
they can plan
right now we're hearing that they can't
plan because they don't know how much
supply of vaccines
they can expect at what time frame that
stops when we're in office
we're also promised to provide regular
updates to you the american people
on our progress and our goals we will be
i promise you
transparent about the decisions we are
making and why we're making the
decisions
you're entitled to know our
administration will lead with science
and sciences
with the with the center for disease
control the national institute of health
that will be free and totally free from
political influence
a surgeon general who's independent and
speaks directly to the american people
the fda whose decisions are based on
science and science alone
speaking directly to you look
while millions of americans have already
gotten the vaccine and millions more are
already to get it
we also know we need to address vaccine
hesitancy
and build trust in many communities
we know that's the case for example in
black latino and native american
communities
people who have not always been treated
with dignity and honesty they deserve
by the federal government and the
scientific community throughout our
history
we also see that disinformation
campaigns are already underway
to further undermine trust in the
vaccines
our administration will launch a massive
public education campaign to rebuild
that trust
we'll help people understand what
science tells us
that the vaccines help reduce the risk
of coping infections
and can better safeguard our health and
the health of our families and our
communities
it's a critical piece to account for a
tragic reality of the disproportionate
impact this virus has had on black
latinos and native american people
who are being infected about four times
the rate of white americans
and dying nearly three times the rate of
white americans
this is unacceptable it's unconscionable
equity is central to our covert response
and the vice president and i commit to
making sure communities of color
and rural neighborhoods those living
with disabilities
and seniors are not left behind in our
vaccination plans
look our plan is as clear as it is bold
get more people vaccinated for free
create more places for them to get
vaccinated
mobilize more medical teams to get shots
in people's arms
increase supply and get it out the door
as soon as possible
this will be one of the most challenging
operational efforts ever undertaken by
our country
but you have my word and we will manage
the hell
out of this operation but as i said last
night
we need funding from common congress to
make this happen
and i'm optimistic i'm convinced
the american people are ready to spare
no effort
and no expense to get this done
all these steps will take some time it
may take many months to get where we
need to be
there will be stumbles and yes i know so
much has already been asked of you
and when we're sworn in next week we're
going to ask you to keep the faith and
keep following what we know
works
one of our 100 day challenges is to mask
up everyone
the day we're inaugurated i'm going to
ask you to mask up for the next
100 days this is not a political issue
and i will issue an executive order to
require mask where i have the authority
to do that
in federal worker for federal workers
and federal property
on interstate travel like trains and
planes
we'll also be working with mayors and
governors in red states and blue states
and require ma
and ask them to require masking up in
their cities and their states
look i hope we now know this is not a
political issue this is about
saving lives
i know it's become a partisan issue but
what a
stupid stupid thing for it to happen
this is a patriotic act
we're asking you we're in a war with
this virus
and experts saying have shown that
wearing a mask from now until april will
save
as many as 50 000 lives
quite frankly it was shocking to see
members of the congress
while the capital was under siege by a
deadly mob of
thugs refusing to wear a mask while they
were in secure locations
i'm so proud of my congressman right
here in the state of delaware
lisa brunt rochester trying to hand out
mass while people are lying on the floor
huddle up you know republican colleagues
refusing to put them on
what the hell is the matter with that
it's time to grow up
the result at least four members of
congress today
including a cancer survivor now have
covet 19 who are in those rooms
for god's sake wear a mask if not for
yourself
for your loved ones for your country
these are real matters of life and death
we need you to stick with hand washing
social distancing
and avoid indoor gatherings with people
outside your own household
we'll be a partner to the states and
cities so where things are working
we'll help do more of the good work
and when things can improve we'll bring
more resources to bear to get folks
tested and vaccinated
i promise you we're going to work
closely with non-profits and with the
private sector
who we know all want to partner with us
in this effort the more people
we vaccinate and the faster we do it
the sooner we can put this pandemic
behind us
and the sooner we can build our economy
back better
and get back to our lives and to our
loved ones
as we're seeing during this pandemic
we can't solve our problems as a divided
nation
the only way we come through this is if
you come through together
as americans fellow americans
and as the united states of america
vice president-elect harris and i ran
on that vision starting at noon on
wednesday
that's exactly how we're going to govern
and ask for your help
god bless you all and keep you safe and
may god protect our troops
thank you
[Music]
yes
okay
you